booyakasha he's gone over the top can
you make someone pregnant by taking him
up the bottom he's gone below the belt
in America woman can vote but course
cannot but now he's going undercover how
could you not tell your brother what you
do I was spying you know you should keep
that quiet hi lovely to meet you ut oh
so you mastered the British absent in
this film and who do channel when you
speak the Queen's English the Queen I
just I think about the Queen and she
just flows through me complete with the
way yeah then it's the whole thing okay
great and and the what I love about this
film is that nobby has the love interest
of rebel Wilson did you know rebel
before shooting and did you find the
love dachshunds heart watch I had to be
on set making sure that there was no
hanky-panky between those two I just say
hey rebel he's Mary see this ring it's
means something where I come from no I'm
just kidding I wasn't there when they
did those scenes in fact the first time
I saw those scenes were on the trailer
and I was like oh I didn't read that in
the script um but no um yeah no rebel
rebel I've known for a long time so it
was I was very happy she's in the movie
and she's super fun and and in there
maybe you give nabis directions in his
ear and but how good is such a following
your instructions in real life haha he's
great he's girl if there's question
Ellen I don't know how to answer that
without incriminating myself for him I
mean I'm yes I can be bossy even a
simple shopping order for the
supermarket well let's just say I don't
have unrealistic expectations I love it
and so this must have been an easy yes
because you've worked with the direct
tillery before I've slept with the actor
and the producer and the rider cuz
they're the same man I married to him
yeah he's if you think and well I was
already in cape town with the kids so
yeah so once it laughs a minute on set
was it just like your nose it was it's
so much fun this movie is hilarious
Sasha's character that his credit is so
funny we laughed all the time and he
would know his sub perfections he stops
at nothing to get the perfect joke and
yeah I learned a lot from watching him
which is always what you want to do
really when you take on a job you want
to you know you want to gain experiences
and knowledge from the people around you
and he's definitely another level I'm a
big confessions of a shopaholic fan like
absolute big fan and so I feel that we
need to Rebecca Bloomwood back in our
lives would you ever bring her back I
would love to bring becca bloom of it I
love Rebecca Bloomwood I don't know if
anyone else wants a bag but just you and
I could bring of that I wanted the green
stuff I track I really wanna rinse after
this interview and if it'd been set now
though what would online shopping
Instagram snapchat how do you think she
would have coped in this digital era yet
would have been hard because her credit
cards would have maxed out pretty early
on and she wouldn't have had the
goodwill of innocent shopkeepers is that
oh yeah well I told you not to smoke at
your age you should just be vaping
do you have any other skills I can make
my balls look like sayin McKellen has
anyone ever told you you're a very
beautiful woman only a guess called mr.
Bill Cosby that pellet was filled with
the toxin I'll be dead in 90 seconds if
you don't suck it out he can suck my
scrotum where you can let me die okay
what was that written on your gravestone
suck my balls in what font would you
like that